[Musik]
meine männer sind profis die
hochprofessionell und ernsthaft ich
ihren auftrag ausführen
der kern meines führungsverständnis ist
dass sie die führen und die die geführt
werden ein vertrauensvolles verhältnis
miteinander haben müssen
das geheimnis liegt an vertrauen und
zutrauen in kombination mit respekt und
wertschätzung rivalen jens in belize und
haben dort geschaut was macht das ksk im
dschungel
jetzt sind wir über einer spezialkräfte
übung nur dänemark und schauen wie die
soldaten hier ausgebildet werden wie sie
mit der lage umgehen mit verschiedenen
formationen um einfach in eine
geiselbefreiung durchführen zu können
[Musik]
wir glauben einfach dass eine ksk serie
noch einmal auf die rekruten und malin
noch andere serien die vorher bei
youtube gelaufen sind oben was drauf
setzt das interesse der zielgruppe der
jungen menschen am ksk ist ungebrochen
hoch das ksk ist ein mysterium sehr
geheimnisumwittert
es gibt viele mythen und legenden über
diesen bereich und wir wollen ein
bisschen auflösen und so ein bisschen
zeigen was können jungs und mädels
diesem verband wirklich und so ein
bisschen mit diffusen meinungen die über
diese truppe gestehen einfach in
deutschland auch aufräumen
mein name ist robert lehmann ich bin 35
bei dieser serie
man möchte ja gerne den themen und auch
den menschen ein gesicht geben wenn man
welche emotionen sehen man möchte
vielleicht auch mal ein schweiß blut
wenn euch das einfach reden menschen
sehen und man hinter dieser maske des
ksk blicken und das mache ich
grundsätzlich für die youtube
zuhörerschaft dass man eben auch mal den
sieg
der sich vielleicht findet quält und
wenig schnell
jetzt geht's los da ist davon ab schon
haltung eine ungefähr es einfach raus
mega geil sagt dann öffnet die kappe und
dann ruck und du schwebst und guckst
über den mega coolste landschaft im
besten licht besser kann es nicht sein
ultra coole jeder sollte das mal
probieren es war mein erster
tandemsprung daumen hoch
das hier ist ab heute haben sie den
lippen ich habe jetzt 24 stunden sieben
tage die woche daheim schon ans herz
also er ist für mich die situation ist
wir haben einen flüchtenden täter
unbewaffnet und apoll es in dem fall die
gewalt und das heißt keine größere
einschränkung für den täter er wird
trotzdem gestoppt ähnlich wie bei der
polizei den hund mitzunehmen
die heizung die wir gehen einfach
deswegen weil auch ein teil der familie
ist aber das geht uns natürlich mit
allen kameraden so aber wir sind alle
perfekt ausgebildet dafür was wir tun
wenn ich jetzt an meinen bereich
angekommen bin in dem ich arbeiten
möchte quasi das objekt liegt jetzt in
gewissen entfernung von drei bis 800
meter entfernung komme ich in die
stellung aber dann meine waffe im
rucksack verstaut
in diesem zustand hole ich die da noch
aus meinem rucksack raus ich glaube ich
die schulter stütze ab jetzt habe ich an
so genannten er sport wie man es kennt
damit ich die bestmögliche dreipunkt
auflage habe ich bin zum ksk in gang
weil ich zu den besten hören wollte
ich habe in der normalen truppe vorher
gedient abgehört david etwas was mich
fordern würde
das habe ich mir angeguckt habe für mich
war sie herausgefunden das ist das was
ich machen möchte
zwischen einsatz und privatleben
umzuschalten funktioniert für mich nur
weil ich so eine starke frau an meiner
seite habe ich versuche natürlich wenn
ich im einsatzland bin mich so oft wie
möglich zu hause zu melden um eine frau
zu sehen und meine tochter zu sehen
das ist schon manchmal hart wenn die
tochter aufwächst und man ist monatelang
unterwegs
das einzige wovor ich angst habe sage
ich jetzt mal ist das wenn ich meine
arbeit nicht mache oder nicht richtig
mache kameraden durch mein fehlverhalten
quasi sterben
[Musik]
also hier zb ist der komfort interest
das ist unser ziel gebäude
es ist hier markiert aber wir stellen
hier quasi ein modell von dem ganzen
zielgebiet auf das auch dass wir später
zugreifen werden damit wir was ich schon
mal detailliertes bild von der lage im
kopf haben wenn wir da raus gehen
hier
red
[Musik]
dazu muss ich unser so
versuchen sie soldaten natürlich nach
dem grundsatz wie du kämpfst möglichst
realistische szenarien darzustellen und
wenn sie immerhin kommen wo jemand liegt
dem wirklichen spaß viel dann
was treibt einen menschen an nicht zu
schlafen nicht zu essen sich unfassbar
zu quälen was bringt diese menschen dazu
waren knie das um andere zu retten die
sie noch nicht kennen mit denen sie
nichts zu tun haben
die größte sorge ist dass wir in der
zukunft möglicherweise nicht ausreichend
viel personal mit den eigenschaften
charakter stärke mentale stabilität und
physische stärke gewinnen können und
wenn wir das nicht schaffen dann haben
wir natürlich auch ein personelles
problem ich wünsche mir dass es einfach
junge männer und frauen gibt die sich
dieser herausforderung stellen die mit
einer motivation zu uns kommen und es
einfach versuchen bei uns teil unseres
teams zu werden sich dieser aufgabe
stellen und hoffentlich dann auch viel
freude an diesen beruf und der aufgabe
haben halver golf 4 unverletzt
tango drei tod juni force10 leben in
gebäude 403 kommen
[Musik]
der stellt sehr aggressiv